that way there's like kids screaming
outside Mexican babies hello guys I'm
Ryan Wright and I'm five four Brown
Pfeiffer here you might recognize her
from a little movie that Warner Brothers
did New Line Cinema blue Mouse whatever
it's called the gallows and you're
you're the lead
you're like the lead of the movie right
I don't know we're all kind of like a
really big yeah yeah whatever are you
talking
I don't know I think Reese's name came
up before me that son of a [ __ ] I know
that's son of a [ __ ] Reese yeah Reese
anyway but Pfeifer is the main female so
yeah we hung out for a while and we
actually met before Fresno I got a vlog
coming up soon of the Haunted maze oh my
god I was in Fresno and Pfeifer was
there and it was it was a total blast so
I thought you know what we got five
right here from the gallows let's take
out some scary stuff together typecast
scary for the rest of my life yeah good
we're gonna check out the trailer for
hashtag horror what if this is actually
scary what if it is then what do we do
then we just go with that reaction that
we have
are you kidding me who is that I thought
it was gonna be a simple matter how bad
it gets you're 12
and what it cools picture ever
are you two not a princess enjoy
yourselves now while you're young
doesn't last long
snatched up those are my favorites
so why don't you guys him
yeah
the movies that looks awesome
I thought we were watching like a
compilation of like movies no that's
what it's called
hashtag [ __ ] that would be really good
I love how like haunting and demented it
seems like it seems really committed to
the craziness of it all I feel like a
lot of these movies send a whole bag and
try to be like slow tension-filled
well put it right out yeah I feel like
they're going like Bam Bam Bam with this
movie man to bring those little
vulnerable little girls oh yeah I like
that I like the feel of I mean no I
don't but I also like the way it was
shot yeah I think it'll I think it'll be
like a great film not just like maybe
not just a great horror movie yeah like
a really good film yeah and I have seen
many wasn't that I think so yes I hope
it okay I'll go to Taryn Manning yeah
she's one of my favorites I get first I
had know where they were going and I
think they were the White House I'm
asleep over yeah I think they're just
having to sleep over it it kind of feels
like it's so Maj to like Stanley Kubrick
style like I get a little bit of The
Shining I'm feeling there you know that
it feels like there's a old school omage
vibe happening Carlos Carlos Jose
Enrique how do you say fat happens me
Rodriguez
Garcia you know what their problem is
they're racist against white people it's
an interesting group of characters like
young girl so it's not like you know you
can find them like oh these are high
schoolers these are like real middle
school girls so if you're they're like
oh hot girls in trouble you're like
that's not what you should be thinking
right you can't be hanging off girls
it's illegal
at that point okay trust me oh my god no
that got a restraining orders got
lawsuits I've almost the shut this
channel down do not think highly of
your old girls in that don't even think
of them no they don't exist in your
brain it's such a vulnerable age and to
make them female is even like 10 times
normal
yeah it's different and they don't look
like I don't know they don't look like
mousy little girls they seem like your
typical just like look you two have
their little cell phones taking selfies
you know yeah they seem like real yeah
that like that's kind of how I feel like
I was I don't feel like my friends when
we weren't that rich like in a big house
like that like frigging fur coats but
you know I got just normal regular
little girls my only problem with this
movie it's the [ __ ] title I was the
title but if that's not what you were
thinking and I was gonna sound stupid
cuz I'm like hashtag [ __ ] that sounds
like a cliche serial killer kind of
slasher flick killing a bunch of hot
young teens in high school that's what
hashtag horrible oh yeah yeah bratty
[ __ ] like spoiled seniors who get
killed who are always on their [ __ ]
phone like that
that's what hashtag horrible long yeah
it kind of makes it sound like a
teenybopper like yeah what it's flashers
is out there called yeah honestly feel
like this has some serious substance to
it but you know what maybe they're gonna
throw this title in our face and be like
boo I mean if you can't get on board
with the plot if you can't get on board
with the story or whatever you can't
deny that a shot well though it's like
really it's shot really well like it's
be bad just every image really Taylor
stuff music video and then they turn
around with these like ghostly faces
it's it's one of those like beautiful
but haunting yeah yeah honestly yeah I
think this I think there's some serious
substance to this so I'm excited it
doesn't just especially like bringing
like middle school girls into it you
would think that maybe it would be like
yeah usually twelve-year-old girls in
horror movies are the freaky ones easy
yeah but these girls are the ones like
getting scared who's the bad guy do we
know I know he's just taking photos of
them and [ __ ]
so it's your neighborhood pedophile
super close to home this is my
biographical
congratulations anyway guys thanks for
tuning into the channel if you're new to
it you can subscribe to the real rejects
pfeiffer brown obviously you can catch
her in the gallows which is now on
blu-ray DVD there's many things you can
follow Pfeiffer on she has an Instagram
she has a vine you have a twitter
twitter facebook fan page yeah okay and
got everything except for snapchat you
know there's no porn apps you think
there'd be a porn app stop I can't find
like one point app dear lord please I'm
so glad there's not a porn app yet cuz
it seemed to come you yo yo shower room
Alex MacGyver getting a shout-out from
Ryan and a person who is no longer
you're gonna be on this channel let's
just say fiver I can give you the
shoutout
no no okay yeah I'll get what you're
saying now getting a shout-out from Ryan
and Pfeifer will make it Pfeifer today
because this other person who will not
be named would make his entire year
there seriously amazing Pfeiffer and
Ryan right and I love them so much
my youtube channel is mr. J Lo's Harley
Q that's cute Alex mr. J Lo's Harley Q
let's see what you look like buddy let's
see if you're old enough for Pfeifer
gosh you know this is a reoccurring
thing it's been like five videos in a
row why do my subscribers look like
serial killers stop your laughing cuz
it's [ __ ] true man come on Neha
serial killers really do you think
that's a hot serial killer you think
that's that's like Dexter Morgan's stop
brother who was like attached to Dexter
Morgan then they were like oh we should
untie these these guys